(man) 'tis the season...
Greetings. I'm Scotty Claus.
For an all-new episode
of "Shark tank"...
I think I just met
Santa Claus.
Where hopeful entrepreneurs
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
I give people meaningful jobs
during the holidays.
Is Christmas gonna
come early?
Look, I don't--I don't want
to be a grinch.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
So greedy on this one.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Ignore everything
they just said.
Did you really
just say that?
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
You come in here and you
charge me ten times more?
Are you crazy?
It's sink...
you've done everything
except get dirty.
Or swim.
Kevin, you don't know me.
Oh.
You don't know
how I can fight, Kevin.
This is a brand.
I really hate it, but I still
want a Christmas present.
Yes! (laughs)
♪♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from working
as a waitress in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
who grew his homemade
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪♪
I'm Juliet Boydstun.
(Australian accent)
I'm Lucinda Gould.
And we're from
Los Angeles, California.
(both) And we own The Coop.
♪♪♪
The Coop is los Angeles'
coolest indoor/outdoor
play and party space.
I love those colors.
(Lucinda) Juliet and I
have been friends
for a really long time,
and we had our babies
at the same time,
and every weekend,
we found ourselves
at these nasty, horrible,
dirty kids' places.
We looked at each other,
we were having the same thought.
(laughs) It clicked.
We could do this better.
(cheering)
Happy birthday! Whoo!
(Lucinda)
The Coop is really unique
because your kids
can come and have a blast.
On the outside patio,
you can sip a coffee,
read a magazine,
chat to your girlfriends,
and feel cool.
There's nowhere else
like that in Los Angeles.
Lucinda and I are
fabulous party throwers.
But we don't really have
the business acumen
and background.
We need the sharks to come in
and help us grow the business.
We're gonna
build This brand big,
and there's gonna be
a coop in every city
in this country.
(laughs)
Whoo! (laughs)
♪♪♪
Hi, I'm Lucinda Lent.
And I'm Juliet Boydstun.
And we own The Coop.
We are seeking $150,000
for a 15% share
in our company.
We've been friends
since we each moved here
about 18 years ago
and at the start of that time,
when we were young and fabulous,
wearing high heels and going
to cool coffeehouses.
And then we had kids.
And everything changed.
We still hung out together,
but our new hangouts
were built for kids--
Noisy,
cluttered with broken toys,
outdated decor,
and cheesy mascots.
We got so sick of these
cookie-cutter party prisons
that we went in search
of a kids' place
that we could enjoy
as much as our kids.
But we couldn't find it.
So we created The Coop.
"Us Weekly" Magazine
just named us
"the hot tot party spot,"
and we want to show you why.
When we designed The Coop,
we went for clean lines.
We kept all the toys modern.
And unlike most kids' places,
we haven't forgotten about
the parents.
We even have a cappuccino bar.
We sell out every weekend.
We cater to movie stars,
rock stars,
television personalities
and star makers,
right alongside
regular moms just like us.
And today we know that
someone in the sharks
is having a birthday soon.
Coming up.
Mark.
So we are throwing you
a shark-themed
coop birthday party.
Oh, lord.
(laughs)
Whoo!
(singsongy)
Happy birthday, Mark.
I don't have birthdays anymore.
I never thought Mark would
invite me to his party.
(Juliet)
Yeah. (laughs)
And it says right here,
"happy 65th."
(laughs)
(Daymond) Thank you.
There you go,
birthday boy.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you.
Oh, look at the cupcake.
(Juliet) All right.
Now who's ready to come play
and party with us?
(Juliet and Lucinda laugh)
(Kevin) Okay, ladies,
let's talk money.
'cause really, that's what
"shark tank" is all about.
Correct.
(Lucinda) Yes.
You say you sell out
on a saturday.
How many parties can you
jam in on a weekend?
'cause I assume
that's when the parties are.
Between six and nine.
How much does it cost?
What are the price ranges?
They range anywhere
from $595 to $4,000.
Depending on--
$600?
For a 2-Hour party.
For 2 hours.
And that supports
how many kids?
15.
That's it?
High-Priced.
But for the--
for the market, actually,
in los Angeles,
we're competitively priced.
What's the average profit
per weekend?
We make $5,000 every weekend,
easily, and some.
How much did you make
last year?
$350,000.
What did you bring
for the bottom line?
Between $125,000 and $150,000.
$150,000.
Is that after paying yourself
or before paying yourself?
After paying ourselves.
We take around $100,000
a year.
Between the two of us.
Between--
(Robert) Wow.
Good for you.
How much does it cost
to open up a single coop...
well...
right from the ground up?
From the ground up,
we got a business loan--
That's how we got our money--
And we had a loan
for $125,000.
And that includes
all the lease--
How much was it?
$125,000.
You built the entire space
for $125,000?
We did a lot of work
ourselves.
We did a lot of it ourselves.
(Mark)
Why not just use the profits
recycle them, and open up
another coop here in L.A.?
it's a big city.
We've talked about that.
I mean, the Manual labor
of actually having
a physical space--
We're open seven days a week,
we're always there.
We're there every day.
(laughs)
So our idea was, like,
with franchises,
maybe we could open 300.
Okay.
(laughs)
Um, so that was kind of
where we were looking at that.
(Kevin) Look, ladies,
on the way
to a successful franchise,
if you look historically
at the ones who have done it--
they take a geographic region
they can actually drive to,
set up 5 to 15 locations,
learn how to manage them,
and then say this model works,
and then do 300 more.
'cause I actually believe
that this could be franchisable.
But you gotta prove it, because
if I was gonna buy it from you,
I'd say,
"you've got one location."
For now...
not an investment,
but, boy, I love your numbers
and I rarely say that
to somebody on "Shark tank."
(laughs) It's True.
We're here because we're...
we need--
Giving you the opportunity
to get in early.
If you give us
what we're asking for,
you're gonna get
your money back
in two years.
I'm out.
(Daymond)
You want $150,000.
Is that all you want?
(Juliet and Lucinda) No.
We want the expertise of
somebody who's a businessperson.
We're creative people.
We're moms.
We don't come from
the business world,
and our business has exploded.
Well, that has to be clear,
because, uh,
you know, we're not here
to exploit people, so...
Well, speak for yourself.
All right.
You would regret
having done the deal with me,
because here, I wouldn't be able
to add any value
and it'd just be money.
And I think that you guys
are rock stars,
and you can open
four or five of 'em,
and have a-a big business
for you guys.
So I would add no value.
I'm out.
All right. Thank you for saying
We're rock stars. (laughs)
(laughs)
You are. You are.
Thank you.
(Robert) I think
the key to the success
of this business
is the two of you guys.
Very successful
at the one location.
Open another one.
I don't understand
why you haven't done that.
You've got the energy
to open 20 of them.
(laughs)
Just go and do it.
Thank you for the shark fin.
I'm out.
Guys, let me
jump in real quick.
First, thank you
for the birthday.
It's the best birthday
I've ever--
Oh, good.
That I've had today.
(laughs)
Two issues. One...
having been through a business
that's very personal
and thinking that I had to have
my stamp on everything
and knowing
how difficult it is
to just grow
those types of businesses,
that's my first concern.
My second concern is,
there are so
many inexpensive alternatives
that the hip, cool, different
I think will work
in the major markets,
but it's gonna be
very, very difficult
to sell to middle America,
even if you reduced
your prices.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Four of the sharks
are out.
Barbara is Lucinda and Juliet's
last chance for a deal.
Lucinda, you said
a few minutes ago to Kevin
that you will get your money
back within two years.
Did you mean that?
I-I do mean that.
Well, then I'll give you
the $150,000 for the 15%.
I don't want anything more,
but I want
your personal guarantee
you'll give me the money back
in two years.
(Kevin) Whoa, shark.
Personal guarantee.
Just to make sure we know
what's going on here--
she's providing you a loan
and she's requiring
as the security
15% equity in the business.
It's called a warrant.
Only a savage
would ask for that.
♪♪♪
Four sharks are out.
Barbara has offered
$150,000 for a 15% stake,
but she wants
a personal guarantee
that she'll get her money back
in two years.
Only a Savage
would ask for that.
Everything you want.
Do you own a home?
I do. (laughs)
I--Juliet does.
Do you own a car?
I own a car, yeah.
So if--If your business
doesn't succeed in--
She owns your car.
She owns your car
and your home.
So greedy on this one.
Can we take a minute?
If they're willing to give
15% of their business
just to get a loan,
you know what that tells me?
That banks are not lending
in America.
What entrepreneur doesn't
put his skin on the line?
They want Barbara's expertise.
Barbara can do a lot
with this.
Wait. They're back.
Just before you start, let's
just summarize where we're at.
So...
Barbara very shrewdly has said,
"if you want my money,
"I'll loan it to you
for 24 months,
"and under the condition
that you pay me back,
I'll also take 15%
of The Coop."
Are you willing to accept
that offer?
One quick question.
We will have
your business expertise?
(Barbara) Of course.
I can't help myself.
We are thrilled to be
in business with you, Barbara.
(Mark) All right.
And now--And now
I'll tell you the truth.
You don't need any help.
You're geniuses.
Aww. Thank you.
I feel so good,
I should hug somebody.
Thanks, Barbara.
I'm so happy.
(Barbara) Oh, Robert,
you look so adorable.
Let me take a picture.
Got it.
Can you send it to me?
My kids are gonna love it.
No problem. I have t-Mobile
super-Fast network.
Done.
Barbara is warm,
but you can tell
that sh--Barbara has
some real savvy.
You know, she's gonna
kick us up a notch.
♪♪♪
Robert, the deal's with you.
Last season, Travis Perry
made a deal with Robert
for his guitar teaching system
chordbuddy,
which was inspired
by his daughter.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
♪♪♪
(Robert)
We're here in detroit today.
Travis thinks I brought him up
for another business meeting,
but I've got a bit
of a surprise for him.
Hey, Buddy. (laughs)
(laughs)
You know, I told you that
we'd get you a country artist
to help us, uh,
sell the product,
and I think
I got you somebody.
He's got
a concert here tonight.
Country superstar--
John rich!
What?
(laughs)
Oh, my god!
Oh, man! (laughs)
What's up, Buddy?
(Robert) John is
a such an authentic guy.
Comes from nothing.
He had a dream,
and here he is--a huge star.
And chordbuddy allows anybody
to play guitar
and make their dreams
come True.
Congratulations on
a great american invention.
Thank you.
I don't shake much.
(laughs)
But--but I'm shaking.
(Travis) I've been a fan
of John Rich for years.
And to have him to come and say,
"This is a great product,"
I've got chill bumps
right now.
Can we play a song together?
I'd be honored.
(John) I think Travis
Invented Chordbuddy
from his heart.
He really wanted
to come up with something
that would allow people
the gift of music,
and I-I really think
this thing is gonna become
a worldwide phenomenon.
♪ I was worse off ♪
whoo!
♪ Until I found ♪
(Travis) Since partnering
with Robert,
it hasn't even been
12 months,
and we're already over
$1.5 million.
"Shark tank" Changed my life.
I'm just glad
Robert took the bait.
Can I get an amen there?!
yeah! Oh!
(Robert) Amen.
Rock 'n' roll!
(man) Next into the shark tank
is Donna Mccue,
who hopes to get
the sharks' attention
with her unique take
to a classic dessert.
♪♪♪
Hello.
My name is Donna Mccue.
And I'm the president
and founder
of fat ass Fudge.
I'm asking for $250,000
for 5% of my company.
Wow.
(mark laughs)
What is fat ass Fudge,
you ask?
It's my grandmother's recipe
that I took up
a hundred notches.
It's made with goat milk.
It's lactose free, gluten free.
But it's not glutton free.
(laughs)
(laughs) Oh, oh.
That always makes me laugh.
Chocolate--
It makes people happy.
So instead of
talking about it,
I want to give you
a little taste
before we get the questions.
You could take one.
Take your time,
and you can just enjoy.
Thank you, Donna.
You're welcome.
(Robert) Donna,
which is the best one?
Well, you know what I love
the best is the vanilla.
But that's my preference.
Smooth.
Whoa.
(Barbara) Deliciously smooth.
(Donna) This chocolate--
(Barbara) mmm.
I'll tell you why
it's so good.
Years ago,
I always wanted to be
in show business,
and every time I didn't get
a part or something,
instead of beat myself up,
I would beat that chocolate.
So I got really good
at making chocolate--
years of not getting things
that I wanted.
It was at my 60th birthday,
my whole family--
Dougie, Donna, Dana, Debbie,
Dennis, Daryl, Danny,
and Mary-Katherine--
We all came to my party,
plus all my friends...
(laughs)
I gave them little goodie bags
because This is a special treat.
Donna, I gotta know--
Mary-Katherine?
Why not a "D"?
my mother prayed
to the virgin Mary
that she wouldn't have
any more kids,
and if she didn't have
she'd name it after her.
(laughs)
So my older brother said to me
when he had that Fudge,
he said,
"you should sell it."
And he said,
"what would you call it?"
and I said,
"I'll call it
"what you
used to call me growing up--
Fat ass."
And that--That idea
never left my mind.
I saw it. I got, like, chills.
I knew that
this would be a hit.
I had a dream about you
last night.
I'll have to tell you.
(Robert) WHOA!
(Barbara) Whoa, baby.
(laughs)
No, I do. (laughs)
I do. I do. I see it.
Donna, you're scaring me.
You're scaring me.
(both laughing)
Give us your numbers.
Okay.
I have a deal
with whole foods. Ta-Da!
Let me just tell you
what's happening.
(Robert) But do you have sales
in the last 12 months?
Yes!
What are they?
(laughs)
It's so exciting. Okay.
(Kevin) Donna.
Yes.
What are the sales
in the last 12 months?
How many dollars?
Okay.
$60,000.
$60,000?
I'm not as excited
as you were.
What?
(Barbara) Oh, my God.
That's not good?
No! Donna.
Oh, my god.
Donna, whatever you're on,
don't give it to Kevin.
That's not good? Listen,
I'm just one person.
(Robert) That's so low.
Huh?
That's so low.
No, listen--
listen to this--
The name alone
is worth a million.
Oh, can I just tell you
another really exciting thing?
Now imagine me--
I'm in a farmers' market.
This is where I started.
All these people come out,
and they wipe me out
of all my product,
like in a wind whirl.
The name brings them to me,
But the taste keeps people
coming back.
(Barbara) Ah.
This is a brand.
This has
endless possibilities.
First off, I think
you're a great actress.
Oh, thank you.
But what do you do?
You're going from farmers'
market to farmers' market
and selling your product
by yourself?
Yes, and then
the second part of it--
now that I'm in whole foods,
they're putting in orders,
and there's another--
(Kevin)
When you say whole foods,
you have one store
you're selling to?
I have two stores.
Do you have a purchase order?
Yes! Oh. (laughs)
For two stores?
Can I say "Yes!"?
(laughs)
(Barbara chuckles)
♪ Hee-Hee-Whoo ♪
(Kevin) Here's the problem,
Donna.
(laughs)
'cause, you know, in the end,
the reality is about money,
okay?
I know.
We're dealing with $60,000
in sales.
I believe that probably
you're breaking even on that.
Aren't we supposed to
negotiate, babe?
Well, here's what--we'll start
the negotiation this way--
I'll give you $250,000...
for 1,000%
of fat ass Fudge.
I'm--1,000%?
But isn't that too much?
1,000%?
(Robert) Oh, my god.
Exactly my point.
It's 1,000%.
It's, like, you know--
How--How long have you
and Barbara been friends?
(sharks laugh)
You don't think that I have
something special, honestly?
I feel I can bring sweetness
and happiness to people
and also I feel
I deserve my own tv show.
(sharks laugh)
(Robert) You gotta be
kidding me.
(Kevin) You're interesting.
The product is good.
So that's what we have.
And that's all you--
stirring it up in the kitchen,
packaging it, and selling it.
If you want to make this
a big business,
one that's worth
$5 million one day,
you need a partner,
because you're nuts.
In a nice way, I'm saying it.
You need a partner.
You need somebody that says,
"listen, Donna,
"you make the Fudge,
and I'm going to figure out
how to make this
much bigger."
That's what's missing
in your presentation.
'cause every once in a while,
lightning strikes
and somebody
dreams up a cookie
or a piece of Fudge
with a crazy name,
and they become rich.
You're half-Baked right now.
You're not fully cooked.
You need the other piece.
You didn't bring it with you,
so unfortunately,
Mr. Wonderful has to say...
I'm out.
Kevin, can I say to you...
Please, Donna.
The difference between
you and chocolate--
Want me to tell you?
Please.
Chocolate doesn't disappoint.
(laughs)
Donna, you're a sweetheart.
Yeah!
I love you,
and I love your Fudge.
I think I found
your other partner.
She's just as crazy as you.
(laughs)
I'm introducing you
to skinny-Ass Barbara.
(Barbara) Donna,
do you mind if I give you
some honest feedback?
Yes.
Okay.
You know what I see
in front of me?
A wildly enthusiastic lady
who likes to make Fudge.
I don't think this has a thing
to do with money.
I think all you want to do is
get out there and meet people,
get attention, share your
enthusiasm for your product,
and that's
what you're doing already.
There's no room in this deal
for any kind of a partner.
Why don't you just keep doing
what you're doing?
I'm out.
I don't know if anybody else
said it--the stuff is great.
Thank you very much.
Uh, and I could sit here
and watch you all day because...
definitely. A good show.
I enjoy your energy.
But, um...
This is not a business for me
so I'm out.
Donna, I think--I think--
You--You--You--
I'm out.
(Kevin) Okay, mark.
Bring it in.
Donna, I don't think
you need me.
I think you're gonna be
just fine on your own.
So I'm out.
Okay. It was fun.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Bye.
♪♪♪
(Robert) Barbara.
(exhales deeply)
Barbara.
Oh, my god.
Fudge is great, though.
Yeah, the Fudge is delicious.
I think she's making brownies,
not Fudge.
(Barbara laughs)
Next into the tank
is Scott Martin,
who's seeking to modernize
a holiday tradition.
♪♪♪
Greetings. I'm Scott Martin.
But I'm more affectionately
known as "Scotty Claus"
and the owner of
the living Christmas company.
(laughs)
I'm here today to offer one
or all of you
a 30% stake in my company
for $150,000.
This Christmas story started
when I was 17 years old,
delivering Christmas trees.
It is absolutely the most fun
a teenager can have
while working.
Everybody's happy to see you--
Hugs, kisses,
milk and cookies.
The arrival of a Christmas tree
means that Christmas
had begun in the house.
But that intense joy is curbed
when you drive by
Two weeks later
and see that same tree that
I struggled to get in the house
thrown out
with the rest of the trash.
And that's when it hit me--
why can't I deliver
a live tree
in a container like this
before Christmas
and pick it up afterwards?
In 2008,
I took my napkin sketch
and turned it into a web site.
We rented a hundred trees
and delivered them out of
the back of my pickup truck.
Last year we delivered
over 1,300 trees.
The time has come
to invite a partner.
You see, just because
it's a good idea,
it doesn't make
my trees grow faster.
But money does.
And with an investor
and the right partner,
we can take this national
and change the way the country
celebrates Christmas.
Thank you.
Scotty Claus, how much
do you rent the trees for?
The average tree
is about $100.
It goes up to $200.
So it might be more expensive
to rent a $200 tree from you
than it would be
to buy it locally?
Right.
Oh.
We're definitely not trying
to go after that market.
(Daymond)
Why would I pay for that
if I could buy it
at the same price?
We deliver it to your house
and we pick it up afterwards.
You don't want a tree.
You're looking for
the service of a tree.
Half of the fun of the tree
is going to pick it out
with the family,
you know--
(Barbara) Only for
the first five years.
After that, it's a pain
in the neck.
Yeah.
(Robert) True, Barbara.
What is the process
of picking it out?
Right now,
you can go on-Line.
We have five different trees
to choose from.
We have elves--
Every one has Christmas names--
We have Justin season,
gregnog.
These guys deliver
that tree to your house.
(laughs)
Then pick it up afterwards.
How many markets
are you in?
Right now,
it's Southern california.
(Robert) I like the idea.
Like Barbara said,
first five years, going in the--
in the forest, cutting down
my own Tree was wonderful.
After that, I want somebody
to deliver it.
Going into the forest
and cutting it down?
I didn't say go in the forest
and cutting it down.
(mark and Barbara laugh)
Is that croatian?
No! That's the kind of...
(Scott) Let me tell you,
there's people--
Hardy guy I am.
I go into the forest,
I cut my own tree, mark.
So the cache is,
it's the same tree every year,
it becomes part of our family?
Yeah.
The whole symbol
about having a tree
is something that's alive
in your home,
and the difference of having
something slowly dying
in the corner
or plastic in the corner
as opposed to live tree
is a completely different
experience.
What are the sales?
$150,000.
$150,000 in your season,
which is basically one month.
Yeah, it's a 2-Month season.
And what's your profit
on that?
$33,000.
And that's after
paying yourself?
No, I have not paid myself.
Do I have to pay
if I kill the tree?
On the web site, it says
that there is a penalty.
You go on the naughty list
and--And you get fined.
The fact of the matter is,
if someone's gone
out of their way to rent
a living Christmas tree,
they tend to take care of it.
What do you need?
So I need capital
and infrastructure.
I need a nursery with
an automatic irrigation system.
I need to be able to plant
my own trees from seedlings
and grow them
all the way through.
Then I control my inventory.
Let me tell you all the ways
I hate this business.
Number one, I hate it
because it's Only
for six weeks of the year.
Sure.
Number two, I hate it
because it's more expensive
than just buying it.
So my market is only people
that cumbaya and don't want
to kill at tree.
Sure.
And then number three,
I hate it
because the competition
is a plastic tree
that I can get
that looks identical.
If I hid a plastic tree
in here right now,
you couldn't tell
the difference.
I really hate it. I'm out.
This is very, very attractive
and endearing to me.
It's a green play.
I love that.
I have a-a tree farm.
I've been dying to be
in business with a guy
with a handlebar moustache.
(sharks laugh)
All right?
There's only one thing
higher on my priority list
than being in business
with a guy
with a handlebar moustache.
You know what that is?
What's that?
Being in business with a woman
with a handlebar moustache.
(all laugh)
I'll keep a lookout
for you.
I know the challenges
you're gonna face.
You have the price of gas
going up,
so now you're gonna go
and ship these trees,
then you're gonna pick 'em up
and bring 'em back, right?
The trees grow,
you need to acquire more land.
That means, more fertilizer,
that means more water,
that means more having to deal
with deer and other things
that are killing the trees.
And the--the answers
you're giving me,
you're gonna figure out
are a little Harder
than you think they're gonna be.
So I'm out.
Very sweet of you.
(Robert) Scotty Claus,
I don't want to be a grinch.
I'm not seeing the growth curve.
Okay.
I-I think
it's a good business for you,
not an investment for me.
I'm out.
Okay. Fair enough.
So and--And--And--
And--And so what I'm offering,
it's a $2-Billion market.
One thing we know--
that Christmas is not gonna be
canceled next year.
It's gonna happen.
I feel like I've--I've solved
the deforestation problem,
the convenience problem,
by what we're doing.
(Barbara)
But here's the rub, right?
You've been
in business four years,
and you had a $33,000 profit.
Think about that.
I don't doubt your passion.
Sure.
I'm out
'cause I just don't believe
there's enough profit
in this business.
Fair enough. Thank you.
Okay. What is not
being told here
is what I'm able to do
with the investment I've made
over the last four years,
the dozens of people
I've employed,
and the value
I've been able to create
because I took something
that used to be thrown away
and gave value to it.
I hire vets.
I mean, perfect guys
for delivering Christmas trees.
Guys who know logistics,
know how to get the work done.
But having a business that is
able to give back and make money
and make a profit
is meaningful.
And so I give people meaningful
jobs during the holidays
they wouldn't have had
otherwise.
I set this up
as a for-Profit company
to do well By doing good.
(Mark) Scotty Claus
I-I'm a believer in convenience
with a conscience.
I think you have
some Real challenges
from a capital perspective.
Right.
I think you have
some pricing challenges.
I think you're gonna
have to turn off
the "Let's just be
the nice guy Scotty Claus"--
to that point,
I'm on the "shark tank."
This isn't, you know,
the guppy pond.
I came here
with the idea that
I've gotta be willing
to make some changes.
So if I gave you
the $150,000,
how many more jobs
do you think you can create?
How many more veterans
do you think you could hire?
Oh, man, I could--
I mean, as I keep growing,
I'm--I'm doubling the jobs
because it--it--
I need a set number of people to
deliver the set number of trees.
I mean, that's--That's--
It's 200 jobs.
Okay.
What are you gonna do,
Mark?
Is Christmas gonna come early?
Here's what
I'm willing to do.
I'll give you the $150,000...
and I'll take 40%...
and I'll provide you support.
Okay.
You're
the landscape architect.
So all that side of it
is all you.
What I know inside and out.
We're gonna have to
work together to figure out
how to scale this thing.
What do you say,
Scotty Claus?
(laughs) that to me
sounds like a deal, mark.
Let's do it.
All right.
(Robert) Wow.
(chuckles)
(laughs
and speaks indistinctly)
(laughs)
Santa Claus really exists.
(Mark)
No. I'm not Santa Claus.
Trust me. If I can't make money
at it, it's not happening.
We'll create a web site,
we'll put the pictures
of the guys that we hired
and let them show
who delivered the tree.
Right.
We'll create
a history of every tree,
the families
that have owned it
so there's more connection.
There's so many positives
about this
that if the only thing
keeping you from doing this
a thousand times more
is a little bit of money,
money's easy.
Yeah.
Doing the right thing
isn't always.
(speaks indistinctly)
Appreciate it, Scotty.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Thank you, all.
Boy, did not see that coming.
(Daymond)
I didn't see it either.
I can't explain how excited
I am right now.
It's been something
I have worked so hard,
went through so many long days,
long nights
working at this,
believing in this,
and the fact that mark cuban
believes in it, too,
is so invigorating
and so empowering
that I-I can't wait
to share it with the world.
♪♪♪
Next up are Connor Pastoor
and Jillian Jaccard,
ambitious college students
who believe they have
the next big fashion accessory
for women.
♪♪♪
Hi, I'm Jillian Jaccard,
and this is Connor Pastoor,
and we're the owners
of the partie Poche group.
We are seeking
a $100,000 investment
for a 20% equity stake
in our company.
We're both students
a loyola marymount University,
where I'm pursuing
a double major
in accounting and finance,
and Connor is getting
his M.B.A.
When I used to live with
a bunch of sorority girls,
I witnessed firsthand
a female phenomena
of our generation.
When going out
for a night on the town,
it's commonplace for girls
to stuff their phone,
cards, I.D.
Into their bras...
Really?
To avoid the hassle
of carrying a purse.
Yes, really.
Stop the madness.
Our product is partie Poche,
a novel nightlife
fashion accessory
that conveniently replaces
a handbag or clutch
by carrying a woman's essentials
around her leg.
No one wants to lug around
a bulky handbag
when the whole purpose
of going out is to dance,
be carefree, and have fun.
And not only
does it look adorable,
but it's so comfortable that
I forget I'm wearing it.
As part of this target market,
I can assure that Partie Poche
will sell.
So remember, when you party,
partie Poche.
Jillian, you say "Will sell."
Have you sold anything?
Yes, we sold 200
on our web site.
And then all of a sudden,
we were shipping these things
to maine, to Vermont,
to Virginia...
But if people didn't
know your name...
all over.
How did they find
your website?
Because people are actively
looking for a way
to solve this problem.
How much does each unit
sell for?
The majority of those units
sold for $17.
But we started bumping up
between $17
all the way to $39
toward the end of the 200,
and we ended up selling
about 27 of them
at the $39 price point.
And is there anything
proprietary about this?
Do you have a patent?
We do have
a provisional patent.
You're telling me,
for $100,000 I get 20%.
(Connor) correct.
And because
you're smart M.B.A.S
and accounting people,
what are you saying your
business is worth right now?
So we're gonna
steer you clear--
What is it?
Give me the number.
Let me--Let me--
Let me preface that--
professor O'Leary
wants to know the answer.
Let me--Let me try and steer you
clear of a valuation--
Are you groveling and begging
'cause you know the answer
is crazy?
We want--He wants to know--
okay. Connor, can I take it?
What's crazy is to try
to value a company
that is pre-Revenue.
(Connor) it makes no sense. We
could do discounted Cash flow--
Well done.
Point well done.
Let me value it.
You know what?
But the problem is that--Is--
(Jillian) But I can talk
discounted cash flows
and intangible assets
right now.
One second. One second.
(Kevin) 'cause you know--
Jillian, you know...
bring it on. Let's do it.
You're gonna sell exactly
how many in 12 months?
You don't know.
Yes. Well,
I don't know exactly.
(laughs)
How much are you saying
your company is worth?
Okay, 200--If we sell 200,000
units in the first year--
No, wait.
No, no, no. You asked for--
the question is, when you
impute a value on the company--
I give you $100,000,
you give me 20% of the stock--
What are you telling me
your company's worth today?
I based 2 valuation methods
off of 200,000 units of sales
or 100,000 units of sales
in the first year.
That brought us to
a $4.3-Million valuation
and then
a $1.9-Million valuation.
You still haven't given us
the answer.
There is a number that you have
valuated your company at--
$500,000 is what--
there you go.
That's all.
But--but that's not what
I'm valuing it at
because I realized
that's it not just the cash.
But if you can make
a value 500--
the cash is just an asset--
Okay, you know what?
You wasted Everybody's time.
'cause they had--they don't--
They're not creative
to think about anything else
and they have no ability
to increase the value.
Why isn't it--
So this is the deal--
Well, I bet you she'll be
real accurate about my money
when it comes over there,
right?
Tell us--
She'll have an accurate
valuation of that, wouldn't she?
Tell us about how much
it costs to make these
and how low you think
you can get your cost,
um, based off of,
um, volume.
(Connor) So recently we
partnered with a manufacturer
and, uh, she quoted us
at $4, said and done.
We have the infrastructure
to support the 200,000 units
that I said we can sell.
And I can break--
If we cut it in--
Down into 100,000 units
for one year,
that's $1.9-Million
valuation.
I can--I can break out--
I'm in this space.
It sounds really good,
what you're saying.
Thank you.
It's worth nothing.
Well, we ha--
Not yet. It can't
be worth anything,
which is why we don't try
to valuate in front of it.
But you're asking--
You just said "Not yet.
It can't be worth anything,"
but you want
a half-a-million-Dollars
valuation on our company.
I had a meeting with the vice
president of sales and marketing
at Nordstrom
up in seattle about--
and what did they say?
Loved the concept.
But you need a buyer? Did they
put you in touch with a buyer?
No. He said, "I don't want to
put you in touch with a buyer
until you have
the final product."
(Daymond) right.
But you have put
a half-a-million-Dollar
valuation on
basically a piece of hosiery
with a bag.
Daymond, are you--
maybe it's
the best thing ever...
are you saying that
everything comes back
to one thing in life--
Money?
Yes.
Okay, then let me take it
from here.
You're insane.
(Connor laughs)
This is not worth $500,000.
Under no scenario would I ever
give you $100,000 for only 20%.
$100,000 is what
the whole thing is worth, maybe.
I'm stuck.
I'm choking on it, you know?
Let me address that.
There's nothing
you can say.
If we--
there's not a word--
Another word you could say
that would ever, ever, ever
convince me this--
What about "money"?
we have 50 grand cash
in our account.
(laughs)
Where did you get
the 50 grand?
We had
two people approach us.
Their buy-In, their capital
contribution was 50 grand.
At that time, we didn't
even have a product.
It was an idea.
You still don't.
We do. That--
That will sell.
This one on my leg
will sell on a web site.
So what did you--
Will sell.
How much of the company
did you sell them for $50,000?
40%.
Jillian and I
are 60% stakeholders.
They got 40% for $50,000?
We had nothing
at that point.
Oh, my goodness.
We didn't have a distributor.
We didn't have a designer.
(laughs)
We didn't have p.O.S
hanging in front of us.
Do you see my dilemma?
You still
don't have a p.O.
Wait, wait. But, Kevin...
we have p.O.S
hanging in front of us.
They're--
they are also working.
They're managing partners--
You come in here
with this story...
they work 60 hours a week.
And you charge me
ten times more?
Are you crazy?
No, I'm not crazy...
Well, it's not ten times.
Because that's what
the company's worth.
Guys, you guys
just don't get it.
You don't have a--you have P.O.S
that you can show us?
No, we don't have P.O.S
no, I'm saying.
I have a--one waiting.
I mean, 24,000 units--
You have one waiting.
Oh, I got it.
I just didn't have
a product to give to her.
(sharks laughing)
(Connor) Look, Kevin,
if you were willing to work
and slave on this product--
(Kevin) Connor...
you can have the exact
same rate they got.
Critical mistake
if you think I would ever pay
10 times more than some college
guy got it for 30 days ago.
Are you out of your minds?
Okay, it's five times.
Five times more.
Only five times?
Oh, that's much more exciting.
Well, no, let's talk about what
they brought to the company
because that's worth a lot.
Sure. Cash, right?
They brought cash...
Cash--
But they also--
they brought a designer,
a supplier in are area that
can produce any quantity,
literally any quantity,
up to a million units
within a year.
By the way--
That's invaluable,
to find a supply chain
that is well-Oiled.
All right, look, look--
That is not invaluable.
That's everybody.
I-I--
to find a supply chain
that is well-Oiled?
That's everybody.
That's out there.
I am very, very worried--
That's everybody.
That's something we didn't have
before we had them.
What do you think
factories exist for?
(Barbara) Talk.
(Kevin) listen, I'm very worried
for both of you
because what happens
if you come in here
with a crazy valuation--
Sometimes a lightning Bolt
comes from the ceiling
and Fries you.
And I think that's happening
right now.
I am out.
Gone. Out.
And I forbid any of these sharks
to get involved with you.
Wow. Well, let me, uh,
double back
and start talking about
the demand again,
because I-I know
it will sell.
I'm standing here,
and that $500,000 valuation,
Kevin, it kills me.
Next week I can sign
a $124,000 purchase order.
Next week.
Is that--Is that right?
You think that, right?
And I'm gonna give away
20% of my company
for a $100,000 to you?
You have such a thick skull
that you're not listening to us.
Mm-hmm.
You're not getting
what we're saying to you.
I have about
ten apparel companies,
and I can't get
a $125,000 opening order
on a new product line.
It just doesn't happen.
What if your board member
works directly with...
Who cares where
your board member works?
That doesn't--
who cares?
The way stores Work is...
who cares who your--
they give you a small order,
they test you.
Then they come back.
Everything you've said here
is incorrect.
It's just theory.
(Robert) You know,
the success in business
is by going out
and actually selling stuff.
I find it so arrogant
of you to--
to be so flippant about
your ability to get orders
when you don't have
any orders.
You've done everything
except get dirty.
(Connor) I completely
appreciate that.
And believe me when I tell you
that I am willing
to get out there,
to put in the 80-Hour weeks,
and to slave
to make this thing happen.
And that's going back to what
that $500,000 valuation is,
is you're buying us.
You're buying our time,
our emotion, and our passion
to make this thing happen.
It doesn't matter
who you know.
what connections you have.
None of that crap matters when
you get out in the real world.
Go out, get dirty,
get some sales.
I'm out.
You came in here
with no orders, 200 sold,
and you said, "It's worth
a half a million dollars."
I know. We gave you guys a deal.
I'm 100% aware of that.
(Robert and Daymond laugh)
(Kevin) I believe him.
All right. Go ahead.
He gave us a deal.
I'm--I'm thinking Bambi
about to meet godzilla.
I mean,
that's what's gonna happen.
You're gonna walk out
of the shark tank
into the real world,
and it is going to
eat you alive.
You don't know me, Kevin.
You're gonna be kicking--
You're gonna be
kicking yourselves...
alive.
That you didn't get in
with us.
Oh, my goodness.
Kevin, you don't know me.
(Kevin groans)
You don't know
how I can fight, Kevin.
(Barbara) I don't think
This is gonna sell, honestly.
And you know what?
Your wild-Eyed enthusiasm
makes you blind.
Every time a shark went out
here, you just kept talking.
That is amazing to me.
I think you really have to go
into the Real world--
Test this thing--
Before you ever involve
other investors.
Barbara, let me clarify
for the rest of the sharks--
See? You didn't
even take a breath there.
"Barbara, let me clarify."
I don't feel listened to.
I'm so out on this.
Uh, I put
my whole savings
into this company.
The saying is, you know,
life is a cruel teacher.
She loves to give you
the test first
and the lesson later.
And you'll learn
sooner or later. I'm out.
Hey, Mark.
So A.E.G.,
100,000-Plus attendees,
100,000--
Shh.
Calm down.
Ignore everything
they just said.
They're 100% wrong.
(chuckles)
Four sharks are out.
Shh.
And Mark Cuban
is Jillian and Connor's
last chance at getting a deal.
Just calm down.
Ignore everything
they just said.
They're 100% wrong.
You guys remind me of me
when I was 21.
You're trying to win
every battle.
That's what being competitive
is all about.
Now I tried
to ask the questions
that would educate me about
where you're going strategically
and could I add value.
(chuckles)
Tell me about
your infrastructure.
Really quick.
(snaps fingers)
Ten seconds or less.
What--what do you have?
So we have a design,
so we can design New products
in different colors,
different sizes.
Great. So you have someone
who can make 'em and build 'em?
Yeah.
Okay.
And the 200 you sold at
your web site was how long ago?
It was six months ago.
Okay, why have you not continued
to sell them on your web site?
Because we ran out.
(laughs)
Okay, so you have $50,000
in the bank.
Why didn't you use that money
to fulfill the orders?
Because we--we couldn't
make any more of those.
That was with a small designer
who did freelance work
with a supply chain that
Connor put together...
(laughs) That was amazing
for his first whack at it.
Okay. Shh.
Don't go on a tangent.
Okay?
So you have $50,000
in the bank,
and you've gone six months
without selling anything?
We just secured that
a month ago.
Okay, in your model,
in your business plan,
you've gone from nothing,
basically,
to 200,000 units.
Mm-hmm.
What got you from nothing
to 200,000 units?
What percentage was on-Line,
what percentage was
going to have to be retail?
15% was retail
through the web site.
85% was--
Okay, you mean on-Line.
85% was wholesale.
Or we can change up
that ratio.
It could be one of those
internet on-Line sensations--
50/50.
See? But now you're waffling.
What you just told me is,
you don't really know
what you're going to do.
I know who I'm gonna
sell it to...
I mean, what--
in the next--
I know those 100,000 units.
I know. I--look, I get--
I get
that you believe in it.
I was hoping I could prove
these fools wrong.
And you didn't.
No, unfortunately not.
If you would've come back
to me
and said, "'a,' this is
what I'm gonna do--
'a,' 'b,' 'c,' 'd,'--
to get to 200,000 units"
and it made
crystal-Clear sense to me,
the hun--Then the $100,000
is nothing.
So for that reason, I'm out.
Can I stop you there
and try again?
No, I'm out.
Well, we do have a plan,
and that--Our last one
was the meeting
that we had last week,
so that's the first one.
We have--We--
Jillian, Jill...
good luck.
Go get 'em, guys.
All right.
Thank you, guys.
♪♪♪
You know, in the end, Mark,
the most important thing
about that pitch is,
we were right,
and you were wrong.
End of story.
On that pitch,
I'll give you that one, Kevin.
Wow.
That's a first.
Yep.
(Barbara)
That is a first.
Steve jobs said,
"stay hungry, stay foolish."
And that's exactly
what we're planning to do.
We're hungry and foolish.
(chuckles)